hi guys welcome to today's live session
by simply learned I would be starting
soon let's just wait for people to join
today we are going to discuss a very
exciting topic on DevOps
you
okay great
I can see a lot of people have joined
welcome guys to this live session now
without further delay let's go ahead and
start with this session on top 10
reasons to learn DevOps also before I
begin please to hit the bell icon and
subscribe to our channel to never miss
an update so today we will be talking
about one of the booming technology is
used which is DevOps we will first look
into what is DevOps then we are going to
dive deep and understand the top 10
reasons why you should learn the verbs
we have a quiz for you in this session
and one lucky winner gets a chance to
win an Amazon wardrobe so stay tuned for
that
towards the end of this session we have
a question-and-answer session where I
will be addressing your queries so do
feel free to put your questions in the
chat section and finally I will tell you
how simply learned can help you build a
career in DevOps
so what is DevOps DevOps is a
collaboration between the development
and operation teams which enables
continuous delivery of applications and
services to our end users before DevOps
there was a lot of communication gap
between the development and operation
teams the code that used to work fine on
the development side would create the
lot of errors on the operation side this
in fact led to a lot of issues the
biggest issue was the delay in project
delivery the solution to this was DevOps
in DevOps the operation and development
engineers participate together in the
entire lifecycle from the design through
the development process to the delivery
of the software to the end-users it
enhances the process to deliver the
software faster and a software of high
quality if there is any bug or error it
is fixed at the right time rather than
dragging it to the last phase
let's now look into the ten reasons why
you should learn the wops
so at number 10 we have technical
cultural and business benefits of DevOps
let me explain each benefit one by one
so first we have the technical benefits
continuous software delivery is the most
important process of delivering the
software in smaller increments to ensure
that the software can be released at any
time with this approach of DevOps the
team will always be ready on delivering
anytime it has the benefit of having
less complex problems to fix the code is
tested at every stage and both the
development and operation teams make
sure that the complexity is reduced to
great extent
DevOps also has the benefit of faster
and easier resolution to every problem
if any bug or error is found it in
earlier stage it is fixed and then moved
on to the next stage
hence this way at the final stage there
will be zero or minimum number of bugs
moving forward let's look into the
cultural benefits of DevOps the workload
is divided equally between all the
employees so no individual is under the
pressure to code test debug an entire
software this results in a team that is
happy and more productive since DevOps
is a collaboration between the
development and operation teams if any
issue arises on one side the team is
always ready to help and the employees
are engaged to make sure that the
software is as the end user requires and
hence is delivered at the set date
the ops helps in increasing the
professional development opportunities
finally let's look into the business
benefits of DevOps
the basic principles of DevOps that is
automation continuous delivery and quick
feedback cycle aim to make the software
development process faster and more
efficient being an extended version of
agile methodology DevOps ensures that
the complete software development
lifecycle goes smoothly by promoting
collaboration between the teams
DevOps offers continuous feedback so
that the errors are fixed in time and
the releases are done fast though these
days the development teams need to break
down the interdepartmental constraints
and collaborate as well as communicate
in a dynamic round-the-clock environment
DevOps gives a way to improve the
business agility by providing an
environment of mutual collaboration
communication and integration across the
various teams in an IT organization all
the team members are responsible for
meeting the quality and timeline of the
software deliverables with devops
organizations can improve the deployment
frequency recovery rates and hence
result in a lower failure rate with
every new release it is possible to
ensure the reliability and stability of
an application when applications perform
flawlessly in the market organizations
reap the benefits of greater customer
satisfaction
at the 9th position we have work with
good developers poor code is all too
common
sadly users arrive at the realization
when it's too late the fact is some
developers are good at what they do
while others have poor coding skills a
team of software developers consists of
excellent good average and poor
developers it is important that the bad
cause generated by many developers need
to be stopped else it may increase the
production time DevOps helps in reducing
the bad code limits as the bad code
cannot go to the next phase until it is
fixed also a team member who is terrible
at coding could be good at any other
different roles and vice-versa retasking
team members earlier in the process
prevent wastage of time and resources so
in this way DevOps
eliminates bag developers and ensures
that the team comprises of good
developers next at 8th position we have
increased efficiency
did increment an efficiency level it
results in speeding of the process of
development and also makes it error-free
DevOps can also increase efficiency
through automation there are many ways
to automate tasks in DevOps DevOps
allows engineers to focus on those stars
which are not automated there are
certain tools of acceleration that
increased the efficiency they are the
cloud-based platforms or other scalable
infrastructure which help in increasing
the access of the team to the hardware
resources and hence speeds up the
process of testing and deployment
operations with the use of build
acceleration tools the code compiles
faster
they may be a process that helps in
embedding parallel workflows into the
country's delivery chain so that the
delays are avoided
moving on at 7 position we have a better
organizational culture
with the help of divorce there has been
an improvement in software development
the development and operation teams are
more focused on performing together
Rad's it having separate goals the team
is more focused on production if both
the teams are combined it will result in
innovative ideas in a very efficient and
effective manner
there is improved collaboration and
communication between the team members
DevOps facilitates better understanding
among the team members and this
understanding increases worker morale
next at the 6th position there is faster
release of software it is true that
DevOps makes the process of software
development agile hence it leads to the
timely release of the software companies
can quickly study the behavior of users
and incorporate the changes to come up
with a better product this in turn helps
the organization to stay competitive
there is a reduction in rollbacks
and failure rates regarding deployment
and the time that is taken to recover
with better products devops reduces the
time for cycles of development and also
ensures a faster rate of innovation at
position Phi we have better knowledge of
software delivery lifecycle once you get
to know about DevOps you will get a lot
of information about the software
delivery lifecycle it is divided in two
main phases like planning analysis
design implementation testing and
integration and maintenance in the plan
phase initially there should be a plan
for the type of application that needs
to be developed getting a rough picture
of a development process is always a
good idea in analysis a detailed study
of requirements is done to check whether
all the requirements are available or
not the list of all the requirements
like Human Resources hard way software
required to accomplish this project
successfully will be clearly analyzed
and listed out here in the design phase
the whole project is divided into
modules each module in two sub modules
by drawing some diagrams using unified
modeling language the pseudocode will be
prepared at this phase in the
implementation phase the application is
coded as for the end user requirements
Cora now has
to the coding there lapis will develop
the actual source code by using the
pseudocode and following the coding
standards the testing and integration
phase is the most important step of the
application development here the
application is tested and rebuilt if
necessary the multiple modules of quotes
from different programmers are finally
integrated into one then finally the
application is developed and delivered
to the end-users the final phase is
maintenance once the client starts using
the developed software then the real
issue start coming up in this stage the
team is required to fix the issues roll
out new features and refine the
functionalities as required
and the foot position we have Boost
product quality the concept of DevOps
does not allow mistakes in the stage of
methodology when what the operation and
development stages are done correctly
with no errors then it will result in a
release of better and improved product
quality this leads to a cleaner more
efficient code and hence increases the
software quality with each release the
devas process brings better quality to
the development process and reduces the
chances of unplanned work at the third
position we have exposure to trending
technologies and advanced tools
divorce works with a variety of tools
few of them are Nagi owes chef Dhaka get
selenium puppet kubernetes ansible and
many more you will get a chance to
understand and use all these tools and
learn how to design develop deploy and
maintain an app or software with the
help of these tools
apart from that by knowing all things
about such software and tools you can
increase your chances of getting hired
by the best companies at the second
position we have increased your
professional credibility by obtaining a
divorce or vacation you can increase
your professional credibility this
certification will help you to let the
others know that you have sufficient
skills in monitoring our software's
performance easily write and code with
scripts and hansung the software
security to a greater extent providing
the best IT hardware you will be able to
troubleshoot various issues in the
software and finally you will be able to
connect software's databases and much
more to ensure effective functionality
42% of companies are now preferring
open-source jobs and want candidates
with DevOps skills so if you want to
become a part of developing the DevOps
your market then this is the perfect
time to start getting DevOps training
and finally the top reason to learn
DevOps is to get a perfect job and
increase your salary DevOps is a very
popular career choice now researchers
have also shown that in the coming years
DevOps will be the main hiring criteria
to 46% of the IT companies however they
are not sufficient experts who can match
the requirements that's why they are
massive opportunities for candidates
seeking DevOps jobs besides when it
comes to salary you can earn a lot of
money on an average a divorce
professional gets a pay of ninety nine
thousand six hundred and four dollars
per annum in the United States and a
divorce professional in India gets an
average salary of six lakhs two thousand
rupees per annum now let me recap and
call out all the ten reasons for
learning DevOps
once again at number 10 we had the
technical cultural and business benefits
of DevOps at number 9 we had worked with
good developers at number eight we had
increased efficiency at number seven we
had a better organizational culture at
number six we had faster release of
software then at fifth position we had
better knowledge of the software
delivery lifecycle and the fourth
position
we had boost throttle T and at third
position we had exposure to trending
technologies and advanced tools at the
second position we had increased the
professional credibility and finally at
the top position we had get a perfect
job and increase your salary with that
let's come to the most exciting part of
the session today which is the quiz so
brace yourself and answer it correctly
as one amongst you stands a chance to
win an Amazon Mojo so here is the
question which of the following is not a
crucial step in their webs lifecycle
your options are as follows a
integration be monitoring see agile
development or is it D configuration do
put your answers in the chat section
along with the email id you can also put
your answers in the comment section in T
and we share it as a story we'll be
announcing the name of the winner on
Monday that is 20th of April so I can
see a lot of questions in the chat
window ok so one of the questions I can
see here is this programming knowledge
necessary for getting a job in the
DevOps wheel yes knowledge of
programming is absolutely necessary to
land yourself a job in DevOps you should
have good hands-on experience working
with C C++ or Java and this will help
you write codes to build various
applications and automate tasks so
another question someone is asking is
how is agile development methodology
different from DevOps well agile
development methodology involves
continuous development and testing in
the software development lifecycle
process it focuses on it-- reiative
incremental and step-by-step development
of an application while DevOps is a
culture that promotes collaboration
between the development and operation
teams this allows faster automatic
deployment of code to the production
server it
helps to increase in organization speed
to deliver applications and services
there's one more question asked by
someone I want to become a DevOps
engineer what are the skills I should
learn so to become a DevOps engineer you
should have excellent knowledge of
programming it could be in Java Python
or C++ that is a major prerequisite then
you need to have a good understanding of
the DevOps lifecycle and the various
tools that are used for carrying out
different tasks some of the tools you
should know are get Jenkins maven chef
puppet selenium talker and kubernetes
knowledge of cloud-based technologies
such as AWS Azure and Google cloud
platform would be an advantage so this
is another question someone has asked
are they any demo of certification exams
which one can take that would help them
grow in the career honestly there is no
official certification body who conducts
their woe of certification exams but
there are few third party bodies that
provide certifications which have a high
demand in the market you can go for the
AWS certified dev ops engineer
professional exam I offer the Microsoft
certified as your divorce engineer
expert exam also if you looking for
certifications in individual tools you
can choose docker certification there is
a certified kubernetes administrator
program and there's Jenkins and puppet
certifications exams conducted by the
company itself now let me tell you how
simply learn can help you learn DevOps
so that you can start your career in it
so guys this is the official simply LAN
website and I'm going to show you the
different types of DevOps courses in
Pilon office
so first is DevOps ingénue let's go
ahead and look into that
you
this is a master's program and test 7
plus real-life projects you can see the
course curriculum here that is git and
github training dev of certification
training they also need WS and more
you can see the learning objectives
the tools covered here are maven ansible
chef puppet saltstack Apache Jenkins
dream city and many more
you can see the course curriculum
you
and you can see the electives that you
can choose okay let's go back and look
at another certification
we had the devil certification training
you
so here we have 56 hours of blended
learning over 10 industry projects with
integrated labs 24 hours of live demos
and you have flexibility to choose the
classes the skills covered our DevOps
methodology version control systems
continuous integration and deployment
tools and jenkins teamcity maven and
many more
so you can see the benefits here the
annual salary of a DevOps professional
the companies that are hiring DevOps
professional
you
then we can see the course curriculum we
have introduction to DevOps version
control systems continuous integration
continuous deployment then we have
software an automation testing
frameworks we have containerization with
talker and much more and you can see the
various tools that are involved in this
then we have our industry projects
so guys in this way simply loan can help
you get a DevOps certification before I
end this session let me read out the
quiz once again for those who missed it
which of the following is not a crucial
step in DevOps lifecycle your options
are as follows a integration be
monitoring see agile development or is
it D configuration please put your
answers in the chat section along with
your email id
you can also answer it in the comment
section with your email id one lucky
winner will win an Amazon voucher the
winner will be announced this Monday
that is 20th of April do subscribe to
our channel to know who the lucky winner
is you will share the winners name on a
simply known community and put it up as
a story The Watcher will be sent to you
over the mail so don't forget to put
your email ids
you
you
so that brings us to the end of this
live session we hope you found this
information helpful if you've enjoyed
this video please like and share it and
don't forget to subscribe to the simply
learn Channel
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply long
you